how to make big decisions to me making a
big decision isn't about making a list
of your pros and your cons and why you
should do this or why you shouldn't take
that deal making a big decision comes
down to your values who are you
or what does your company stand for when
you figure that out it's way easier to
make the big decisions in your life I
reminded of the story of Steve Jobs when
he started up a computer he dropped out
of school he sold all his stuff he sold
his car he sold his possessions to
finance this company he left the safe
path the path everybody said was the
right thing to do graduate school get a
job this is the safe way to go he left
all that to start a business and if that
wasn't crazy enough he did it in
computers and people said you're nuts
like computers why computers nobody
needs a computer there was no market for
computers it didn't exist the only
people who bought computers were huge
corporations there was no need for a
personal computer it did not exist it
was a crazy decision for him to make and
yet he did it how does he have the
courage the confidence to go out and
make this company because he wasn't
looking at his list he wasn't looking at
the pros and the cons he was listen to
his values he knew that this thing had
to get done this was part of him and he
had to create this and often you'll find
that when you look at your list of pros
and cons the answer that you come up
with is not actually the answer that is
best for you because the list is going
to represent everything you can think of
your thinking with your head and it's
always limited to a world that currently
exists where we think with your heart
and you think with your values and the
person that you stand for when you think
of that then you can create a new
world and you can have the courage to
chase something to follow a dream that
may not make sense anybody else but
feels right to you when I was in
university I had a part-time business it
was a software company I had with two
friends and I was making 300 bucks a
month trying to get this thing to go and
I remember when I was graduating I got
opportunities to work with two of the
biggest financial companies in the world
opportunities that my friends were
jealous of like they want these
opportunities opportunities that paid 80
to $100,000 a year starting salary 80 to
100 K starting salary I'm here making
$300 a month can barely survive and
here's an opportunity to just totally
transform my life in a second they're
flying me to New York to recruit me
they're putting me up in the
waldorf-astoria and as I go through the
process I just felt like I had to keep
going with my business you know it
didn't make sense logically if I made my
list reasons to do it reasons not to do
it it didn't make sense logically and my
friends were like what you're crazy
how could you how could you not chase
this why are you doing your business
you're making nothing like you you can't
survive you may be out of a company in
three months and and you know it was
close to me but
some something made me want to keep
going and I'm glad that I did because I
turned that business into an
international company and it had clients
in over 30 countries and I sold the
brand name clients like Johnson Johnson
and NASA and I got my business acquired
and then I hooked up with a venture
capital company and now I'm doing this
and I'm so happy with my life and what
I'm doing right now and I can't imagine
what would have happened if I didn't go
this route and it's funny now because
some of those same friends who I who I
had early on who told me this is the
route we should go and they followed
that path they come back and I see them
now and they're they're telling me I'm
Evan I'm stressed out I'm overworked you
know I hate my life I feel like I'm on
this crazy treadmill and I don't know
what to do and I'm thinking about
starting my own business what do you
think and I'm just like um my mind is
blown and I'm happy to help them out
with their business but that was so
close to being me I almost made that
decision and I would be that guy who
hates his life and his super stressed
out and overworked and and logically
that was the right thing to do but I
listened to my values and what I wanted
to accomplish in my life and I just felt
like even though this doesn't make sense
rationally I have to listen to my heart
and go after this opportunity I got
emailed recently by one of my newsletter
subscribers Phillipe and I really feel
for Philippe Philippe is a seller of
Canon products we sells the camera as a
point click and the higher end cameras
and he's found that his sales have
decreased because people are no longer
buying the point and click cameras
they're just using their phones and he
sees his businesses is struggling now
and I feel for him because it's
it's really hard when you have a
business that's doing well and then
starts to crash and you're not sure what
to do you start to panic it's almost
better to have never experienced that
taste of success because when you get it
you hate losing it and Philippe now is
in the point where he doesn't know what
to do and any rights to me is like do i
how do i get people to be more loyal to
me how do I get people to refer more
customers to me how do I get more
related products in here and he's
wondering should I go with network
marketing should I bring in printers and
sell something totally different should
i implement some kind of customer
loyalty program or Points program here's
the thing Philippe until you understand
what it is that your business stands for
you will never have clarity on any of
these issues you're going to bounce
around from idea to idea grasping at
straws trying to make it happen you have
to first understand why did you start
this business and what are you all about
because until you do that it doesn't
matter if you have a customer referral
program or a loti points program because
you're not giving people a reason to
talk about you
if you stand for something important
then people will want to help spread
your message so here's an example say
say you wanted to make photography
available for everybody you believe that
everybody can take great pictures and
you want to show them the way ok if that
is your guiding principle everybody can
take great pictures you build your
business around that what does that mean
it means you're not selling printers it
means you're not selling anything that's
not related to taking great pictures
because everybody can take great
pictures it means that when you are
working on your sales staff when people
come into the store they're made to feel
welcome
I've walked into a lot of camera stores
and they obviously know a lot more than
I do and I feel inferior I feel like
like I'm nervous and I'm worried walking
in they make me feel bad for not knowing
these things I'm asking logical
questions that they seem for some reason
are stupid and they make me feel bad
about it so as a beginner I'm not going
to go back to that so I'm not going to
tell my friends about it so you need to
have your salespeople be friendly to
these people coming in it's part of
everything do you understand once you
get that messaging once you understand
what you stand for it impacts every
decision in your business if you believe
everybody can take great pictures that
has an impact on who you hire how you
hire the types of products you carry
what your store looks like what kind of
marketing you're doing it impacts
everything you're talking about what
products to get into you're worried
about the the phones coming into the
market maybe you should sell phones if
you believe that everybody can take
great pictures and you're educating them
that starts with the phone and maybe
from going the phone they'll go to a
bigger camera afterwards but you're
educating them even on their phone how
to take a great picture and that's a
gutsy decision and a hard one you might
be the only guy in Canon who makes that
decision to go out and sell phones and
people may say Philippe are you crazy
what are you doing you're you're you're
selling cameras you went on the phone
business it doesn't make sense logically
on your list it doesn't make sense but
it makes sense here because you're
following a purpose a mission a vision
that you believe in everybody can take
great pictures and you're helping them
do that and that's a message that people
can spread for you so you have to find
out what that is for you I just made
that one up find out what it is for you
and when you figure that out then your
decision-making becomes easier so how do
you find what you stand for how do you
find what you believe in this is a long
thought-provoking exercise but I'm going
to try to drill it down to three simple
steps for you that you can start working
on right now that will give you insights
into yourself and help you make those
big decisions okay number one
understand why understand why you
started this business why did you start
this business what did you do it for and
and it better not be for money you
started this business for a reason it
was just to make money you're going to
fail you got to start over new business
you look at famous entrepreneurs why
they got started was never for the money
it was to have some kind of impact and
if you're providing value doing great
things and money will come but why did
you start this business write it down
one sentence why did you start this
business that's not about money ok
that's the first part understand why
number two what do you want to be known
for think about it you know you have a
limited amount of time on this world
what do you want to be known for what do
you want people to say about you what's
going to be written on your tombstone
it's not going to be philippe made a
million dollars that's not going to be
yet I guarantee it but I could see it
online saying Evon believed in
entrepreneurs I could see that being on
my tombstone what's going to be on yours
what do you want people to know you for
and again it's not going to be about
money it's going to be about something
more something bigger something more
powerful write it down write it down
right now what do you want people to
know you for what do you want to be
remembered as and number three is
imagine imagine a world where you were
rich okay you had all the money you
needed what would you do what would your
daily life look like because it's not
just going to be sitting on some beach
okay you get tired of that how would you
spend your life how would you make
decisions if money wasn't an issue what
would you do what is your day-to-day
life look like
write that down what project would you
work on write them down from everything
you've written down from those three
points those three important questions
there's a common theme and that's who's
uniquely you you have to ideally drill
that down to one word but start with a
sentence and get closer and closer and
closer and then whenever you're making a
big decision it's easier you look at
your sentence and ideal you look at your
one word and from there you make a
decision for me it's about belief and
specifically believe in an entrepreneurs
when I'm faced with a big decision it
was not about believe it's easy I don't
care how much you're going to pay me
it's not belief I'm not doing it I don't
take on other projects that may not make
any sense financially but are all about
belief and I turn them into big
successes so use those three steps and
find your word believe those are
watching you like the video please give
it a thumbs up below let me know what
you think leave a comment you have a
question leave it leave it below I'll
make a video response and if you like
these videos don't forget to subscribe
to the channel thank you so much and
I'll see you soon